hi my name is Vijay Paliwal I've worked
with midmark corporation we are a health
care company based out of Dayton Ohio
and we have a keen interest in the
Indian healthcare segment hence we
entered this market around four years
back through an alliance I just moved
back to India six months back running
that business and I'm delighted to be
here it's been a great event this is my
first time actually to the World
Economic Forum and I had a lot of
expectations but I would say that the
event actually has exceeded my
expectations I was most impressed by
really the quality of discussions that I
heard in the various sessions that we
have here unfortunately you know some of
the sessions are parallel so you have to
you know miss some but I'm hoping that I
will be able to go online and catch up
on some of these sessions that I missed
overall wonderful experience you know
great management by the World Economic
Forum team wonderful accommodation here
you know very nice hotel good food so
overall it's been a it's been a great
trip
thank you